didn't
[Applause]
[Music]
that wasn't bad
but we'll give it another go this time
I want everyone
from right down on his home street of
Garden Street to the Market Square in
Ballina we've got big screens from Pier
Street operatory and down the key
to here on the banks of the historic
River Moi behind the cathedral are we
ready to give President Biden a
homecoming welcome
[Applause]
[Music]
tonight we are celebrating in Ballina
we're celebrating our history Our
Heritage our culture
and most importantly our people we're
celebrating each and every person from
County Mayo on afar that has come here
tonight on this historic occasion
but we're also remembering tonight the
people who are no longer with us who are
part of the fabric that have made us who
we are a proud County mayor people and
proud Irish people
[Music]
[Applause]
the balance story was not always
celebratory
we've had our difficult times
on these streets and on these laneways
Jordan famine so many people
died and emigrated
many went to Scranton our sister city in
the USA
they went in search of a better life
one man Edward blew it
went to Scranton
like many of him from this area
thousands of us from County Mayo
went to Scranton who went down into the
coal mines worked the railways but
coming out of those coal mines came hope
and came the Edward Blewett story that
has now become the Joe Biden story
[Applause]
[Music]
in Scranton like Ballina
we know where we've come from
we're proud of who we are
and in just a few moments time the
president of the USA is back for the
third time in Ballina County Mayo
[Music]
[Applause]
the T-shirt leovradker will speak next
after t-shirt speaks I hope that you
give a rousing
powerful Western soulful
homecoming welcome
to the 46th president of the United
States of America President Joe Biden
have a great night
[Music]
please welcome p-shock Leo varadkar
[Applause]
President Biden Ambassador Cronin
distinguish guests ladies and gentlemen
Mr President
welcome back to Mayo
[Music]
[Applause]
Falls
a county very close to my heart as well
as your own
and thank you for choosing to make this
such a big part of your visit
the story of Ireland can be told through
poetry and music
but most eloquently it's expressed
through our people
it's a story of longing for a better
life
a better Society
and a better world
a story of unimaginable courage in the
face of loss
and above all it's a story of love
for a country for family and for a
community
it's your story Mr President as well as
our own
so thank you for your lifelong
commitment to peace on our Island
your friendship
your leadership that you've shown and
protecting all that has been achieved
and for everything that you're helping
to do to build a better future here
America and around the world
in this place hope and history
are not often far apart
25 years ago when the Good Friday
agreement was signed
to use the words of Maya Angelou my
favorite American poet
we released our fingers from fists of
hostility
and allowed the pure air to cool our
palms
history she reminds us despite just
wrenching pain cannot be unlived
but if faced with courage need not be
lived again
by facing our past together on our
Island we learned a brave and startling
truth
but nothing is ever truly impossible
in the darkest days of our country's
history
the Bloods and the Finnegans
and countless other families left these
Shores for a better life in the New
World
Mayo has changed considerably and
Ireland has changed considerably since
Edward Blewett fled these Shores during
the worst days of the famine
we are our country at the time starved
of the starved
of food of medicine in despair start of
opportunity and starved for even longer
of basic rights and freedoms
a country that was being denuded of its
people
a country that was not in charge of its
own affairs
today Mayo as you've witnessed is linked
to the World by fiber and by air
it's connected to communities across the
globe through its people
Mayo's home to American companies that
provide good jobs for so many people and
a new Technological University which
provides the greatest passport for all
and education
so here outside Saint maradox Cathedral
we must rededicate ourselves to playing
our part
in the fight between Darkness and Light
Despair and Hope
Injustice and dignity
we pray for the wisdom to guide us
the words to speak up for those without
a voice
the shield to protect our planet
and the strength to do what is right
always
Mr President we know that you're a life
story reminds us that although tragedy
May shape us
it never solely defines us
love of country of family and of each
other moves us forward providing New
Hope and inspiring others along the way
President Biden you are the most Irish
of all American presidents
not because of what is written on your
family tree
but because of what is enshrined in your
soul
we didn't need to gather here today in
our tens of thousands to say welcome
back to Ireland
because in your hearts you never left
thank you very much Mr President we look
forward to your words
[Music]
thank you
please welcome a son of Ballina and the
46th president of the United States Joe
Biden
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
I see the light
hello Mayo
great to be here with you all it's great
to be back in Baltimore during your
300th anniversary
[Applause]
this town
is the home of Ireland's first female
president one of your youngest mayors
and maybe to be Ireland's first female
astronaut Nora Patton
[Music]
thank you for welcoming me back to town
and I also want to thank the t-shirt for
his remarkable Hospitality his generous
remarks and maybe most importantly for
his friendship
I want to thank the bands that played
earlier the current guy you guys are
amazing and the academics let's give
another big hand by the way to The
Chieftains
I remember being with you back in 2016
I'm grateful you came back for one more
time to perform tonight thank you the
chief and your music is incredible and
I've been a long time
fan
my good friend
my good friend into Kenny former t-shirt
a mailman is here with Finola his wife
God lovers you're going to go straight
to heaven
I love you both but most of all
I want to acknowledge my family all the
Bloods
you make me proud you make me proud
all year the words of the great male Poe
and annual Rafferty have been ringing in
my head
and it goes like this he said now the
spring is coming
I shall raise my sail since it entered
my head I won't stay still until I shall
stand in the center of County Mayo
I mean it I had to be here
my son Hunter and my sister Valerie and
I made several stops across mayor today
we visited knock Shrine where I was
hosted by Father Richard Gibbons we also
met out of the blue we didn't know he
was there a former military chaplain
father O'Grady who gave my son last
rights and Walter Reed Medical Hospital
in Washington it was incredible to see
him it seemed like a sign we traveled up
to North mayor Heritage Center where I
learned even more about my roots and
mail Russian led me back here to Ballina
and the saint Murdoch's what a
magnificent Cathedral
I also learned if you go far enough back
you can find a record of one Edward
Blewett who worked for several years in
the ordinance surveyed mapping his
entire area of Ireland
but even before that it turns out he
worked in the Old Baltimore Brickyard
we found a record or I should say the
Historical Society found a record for me
in 1828
he was paid 21 pounds and 12 shillings
to help Supply this bricks for this
Cathedral twenty seven thousand of them
I was able to hold one in my hand today
they're damn heavy as they're heavy
as he labored I'm sure Edward imagined
that one day his family would worship
here
that his children will be baptized here
like his son Patrick was
and that future generations of his
family would Mark the Milestones of
their lives here in their sturdy walls
but I doubt he ever imagined his great
great great grandson would return 200
years later as president of the United
States of America
isn't that amazing
[Music]
and I want to thank you I want to say
thank you I heard you all had an
impromptu celebration the night I was
declared the winner in 2020 election
you decked out the time town I'm told in
red white and blue with cars and crowds
gathered in the Market Square singing
the green and the red of mayo
[Applause]
well I tell you what
it means the world to me it meant the
world of me and my entire family to be
embraced as Mayo Joe son of balana
my mother
my grandmother who was maiden name was
Blewett they're smiling down on me right
now and I can tell you what that song
speaks to me
it goes like Oh the feeling that came
over me to stay forevermore forevermore
stay forevermore
and on the green and red of mayo oh the
green and red of mayo oh the green and
red of mayo
[Applause]
the truth is it is being here does feel
I know we're going to say it feels like
coming home
it really does
over the years stories of this place
have become part of my soul
part of my family lore
it was here where I imagine my great
great great grandfather
took shade under her you trees after
long days of Brickyard
it was here I imagine his children
climbed the Limestone Cliffs and played
in the muddy bogs
fished in the river more
it was here where I imagined one of
those children my great great
grandfather Patrick
stood on the shores of clue Bay and
dreamed of becoming a semen
when Patrick was just a teenager
he set sail for America for the first
time
but the 1850s the famine hit Mayo
particularly hard
he returned to Baltimore to gather the
entire blood Clan mom dad and all the
children
together they boarded The Excelsior
to sales in the United States
just as I imagined
their life here in County Mayo I can
only imagine how hard it must have been
to leave it all behind
to be the only place that ever called
home
a whole loud hope
on shores Beyond
like so many other men and women of male
Edward and Patrick
carried this hope with them across the
sea
they settled in my hometown of Scranton
Pennsylvania and Baltimore sister city
as a matter of fact I knew I was coming
over so you know what I did
I invited the mayor of Scranton
Pennsylvania to come with me
she's here tonight
Paige cognetti
it was here it was there in Scranton
where Patrick raised his own son also
named Edward Edward Francis blew it my
great-grandfather
his Irish Pride ran deep
he helped found the Irish American
Association
now known as the sons of friendly sons
of Saint Patrick a lack of Lackawanna
County he chaired Scranton's St
Patrick's Day Parade in 1897.
for the Ancient Order of Hibernians
he became one of the first Irish
Catholics ever elected to the
Pennsylvania state senate
and it became one of the first of my
family to go to college
earning degree in engineering from
Lafayette College in Pennsylvania
but while Edward had the head of a
scientist at the heart of a poet
years ago after my mom died a lot of her
belongings were an attic I couldn't get
myself to go through them to empty the
boxes
but what I finally did
you know what I found in the Attic
my mother's keepsakes
over 100 poems written by Edward Blewett
Senator Edward Blewett
and one from 1919 he wrote of his
Ireland
from the fairest land except my own
these stars and moon and sun
a citadel of Liberty
my mother's land a room
was it Scranton where my mom Catherine
Eugenia Finnegan met married my dad
Joseph R Biden senior was a wonderful
man
but it was saving grace in the eyes of
the Finnegans
was he had a hanafree from Galway as on
the mother's side
it rescued the fact vines in English
name
together
they raised me and my siblings with a
fierce pride in our Irish ancestry
a pride that spoke to both the history
that binds us but more importantly the
values
values that unite us
to this day I can still remember hearing
my dad say at the dinner table Joey
and I meant this is I give you my words
and by this is absolutely true
he'd say Joey everyone
is entitled to be treated with dignity
and respect
I can still hear my mom say tell me Joey
nobody's better than you but everybody's
your equal
these are the same values I've tried to
pass down to my children and
grandchildren whom I've always dreamed
of bringing to Ireland
in 2016 when I was vice president
that dream became a reality
three generations of my family walked
along Garden Street Redwood blue or
brickmaker and surveyor lived with his
family
it was on Garden Street
we learned the true meaning of the
Celtic expression a hundred thousand
welcomes
matter of fact I think I shook a hundred
thousand hands that day
I also met the extended cousins
who wish that he felt like family I'd
grown up with on Sunday dinners on every
single week his strong bond brought me
back in 2017 when I was a professor at
the University of Pennsylvania
no crowds no motorcades no secret
service just me and my brother Jimmy
coming home to see family
during the trip without the honor
of turning the Sod at Ross common
hospice
as many of you know that hospice is now
open
and thanks to my cousin Lorita Blewett
and many of those those she's incredible
by the way and many of those there's a
marker
there's a marker laid there in
remembrance of my son
Beau passed away in 2015.
a decorated war hero from
Attorney General of Delaware after a
valiant fight with brain cancer
so I can tell you how special it is
that a place
of his legacy
lives here among his ancestors
and thinking about it
I've been hearing my dad's voice again
you always say Joey remember
family
is the beginning
the middle and the end
beginning middle and end
that's the Irish of it the beginning the
middle of man
[Applause]
everything between Ireland America runs
deep our history Our Heritage our
sorrows our future our friendship our
joys
but more than anything hope is what
beats in the hearts of all our people
for centuries even during times of
darkness and despair hope has kept us
marching forward toward a better future
one of Greater Liberty
greater dignity and greater
possibilities
in the earliest days of my nation's
history thousands of scotch hours
alongside George Washington defended
those ideals and then
those Democratic ideas were under threat
during this my nation's Civil Wars
that's when the Irish images came after
the famine more than 150 000 of them
during the fight to defend the liberty
and equality
many serving in the legendary Irish
Brigade
when one other Irish Catholic President
only other one John F Kennedy visited
Ireland 60 years ago you can clap for
him man he was something else
[Applause]
he presented your parliament of the flag
of the Regiment of that Irish Brigade
honoring Ireland's great contributions
to American Freedom it still hangs there
to this day
it's a legacy
faith and Fidelity to freedom to one
another that has been handed down
generation to generation to generation
today the United States continues to
honor that Legacy
including
that one of a male born Marine named
Patrick Gallagher Patrick immigrated to
New York in 1962.
he worked
for the Senate campaign of one of my
political Heroes Robert F Kennedy
a few years later
and he wasn't even a U.S citizen Patrick
joined the United States Marine Corps
deployed to Vietnam
in January of 1966 Patrick's team was
attacked in an ambush
when the enemy hurled the grenade as
team Patrick threw himself on top of
that grenade
he was willing to sacrifice his life to
save his brothers in arms
he survived that attack today but it was
the lord of the Navy cross for his
bravery sadly he was later killed in
action but this year
his name will be honored in iron
as the United States launches a new Navy
destroyer the USS Patrick Gallagher from
male
[Applause]
you know
I've often said
that we Irish
are the only people who are actually
nostalgic about the future
we always believe in a better tomorrow
it's because no matter what
we've always always carried hope in our
hearts
it's hope that lifteth the way through
the darkness and lighted it for us
our strength has helped us overcome
everyday hardships and above all our
courage has allowed us to March forward
in faith even to the face of sorrow and
setbacks
as you know all too well
this is not just the story of our past
but our present and our future as well
earlier this week
marked 25 years is the signing the Good
Friday agreement
25 years of Peace of progress and peace
and progress not just for the people of
Northern Ireland but the people all
across the island
it's a reminder of the importance of
peace
I want you to accomplish when we work
together in common cause
ladies and gentlemen
our world today stands at an inflection
point
where the decisions we make today are
going to affect our futures for decades
to come
and it's in these moments where we need
hope
and courage more than ever
we're facing enormous challenges around
the world
sounds that are too great for any one
country to solve alone
together we must take on these
challenges of disease food insecurity
which continue to devastate communities
around the world
just as
they did in Ireland Generations ago
and I'm so proud to say that Ireland has
not forgotten
you've stepped up as a leader to fight
Global hunger around the world today
we must tackle the crime of crisis
as devastating impacts
to preserve our planet for generations
to come
as I said to the parliament Ireland's
famous Forty Shades of Green now include
green energy green Agriculture and green
jobs
[Music]
and with Russia's brutal aggression
brutal war of aggression is shattering
the Peace of Ukraine and in Europe
we must renew our commitment to our
values our ancestors fought for
what do we are is right for freedom
democracy
it always must be defended
and I want to thank you I mean this from
the bottom of my heart I want to thank
you for your incredible generosity
you've shown
like so many other Irish families across
this country who've opened up their
hearts and homes to tens of thousands
Ukrainian refugees fleeing Russia's
brutal violence I've been there many
times
Ireland remembers
[Applause]
so let me end where I began with the
bricks of this Cathedral
nearly 200 years ago
the bricks touched by my great great
great grandfather
in his hands still hold
up this soaring Nave
and hold it Aloft
like the Irish American story itself
it's a testament to our shared past
present and our future
it speaks
to the sweat of the workers
who raise the spire
of Skyward Brick by Brick just as they
did in communities all across my home
country
you know
over 32 million Americans claim of the
Irish heritage
more would if they could
and I imagine
all the hope and hard work
and brought into those Irish hearts
inspired another one of my great great
grandfathers Edward Francis blew its
poems
this one was from 1925 toward the end of
his life
he called it
the workers
it goes like this the march of progress
cannot cease while harsh and minds and
art and souls are bound in faith
to Sublime things
my friends
people of mayo
this is a moment to recommit our hearts
our minds our art and souls
to the march of progress
to lay the foundations Brick by Brick by
Brick
for a better future for our kids and our
grandkids
one of Greater Liberty
opportunity and dignity
just like our ancestors did for us
I've never been more optimistic and I've
been doing this a long time
I've never been more optimistic about
what we can achieve if we stick together
and stick to our values
this is a time of enormous possibilities
and United by history
Heritage and Hope
and made most of all by courage
nothing is beyond our reach
every time I walked
out of my grandfather Finnegan's home in
Scranton Pennsylvania Joey
keep the faith
not hear someone from the house yell no
Joey spread it
[Applause]
may God protect
all those who serve the cause of peace
and oh one more thing
mail for Sam
mayor for Sam
[Applause]
thank you thank you thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
destination